Judge Judy Scheindlin is the most
watched TV judge of all time known for
equips and catchphrases quick rulings
and no-nonsense style but that gun I
understand that you will pay for the
damage she's been on the air for more
than 20 seasons and Counting but there
are plenty of behind the scenes details
even regular viewers don't know about
Judy under TV court here are some facts
about the outspoken judge and a hit show
you might not know Judy makes Bank in
exchange for her domination of daytime
TV
Sheindlin has been handsomely rewarded
according to the Washington Post
Sheindlin renewed her contract through
2020 for an undisclosed amount but her
previous contract netted her 47 million
dollars per year which she earned
working only 52 total days out of the
year meaning she made $900,000 per
working day that makes shine them one of
the highest-paid if not the highest-paid
woman in all of television and she earns
it largely by just being herself now
they pay me for doing exactly what I was
trying to repress for 15 years pre-show
Fame Judge Judy went on the air in 1996
but in 1993 the Los Angeles Times did a
story on Sheindlin in which they
referred to a work in Family Court as a
highly personal crusade to print order
out of chaos which has assumed folkloric
proportions at America's largest
juvenile justice system
the story eventually led to a now-famous
60 minutes profile which in turn landed
Sheindlin a book deal transitioning her
from public servant to celebrity author
almost overnight
Judy's world record in September of 2015
Judge Judy celebrated his 20th season
which is a remarkable feat for any TV
show let alone one that features a
cranky Brooklynites yelling at people
for 20 minutes why don't you just start
banging your head on the table and don't
stop until I tell you but it was a
landmark achievement on the less and one
recognized by Guinness World Records who
awarded shine Lynn the same year for
having the longest career as a TV judge
at the time of the award Judge Judy had
been on the air for under 19 years which
amounted to 4,500 episodes and more than
nine thousand cases heard as of the
making of this video
Sheindlin is still presiding over her TV
court room and with Judge Joe Brown's
2013 cancellation after 15 seasons it's
unlikely that another TV judge will even
come close to a record how bird got big
there is no doubt that the success of
Judge Judy is largely due to Judy's
powerhouse persona but the chemistry
between Scheinman and bailiff Petri
Hawkins bird is another crucial element
of the show but it wasn't originally
planned that way during an interview in
Hollywood today live bird revealed that
producers had no idea he and Sheindlin
would go into banter but it happened in
the very first episode she looks at me
and she goes s o d di and I just look
and I go yes some other dude done it
that comedy routine was born in that
moment and the bird says it changed him
into a principle player on the show and
ultimately earned them more money but
the crackling chemistry between shine
Lin and bird didn't come out of nowhere
in fact long before shine Lin started
dulling alter acid-tongued judgment for
a national audience she was doing it a
Manhattan Family Court with bird by her
side it was a tumultuous time in bird's
life when he got the unlikely
opportunity to become a TV star he was
working as a counselor at the high
school and delivering pizzas on the side
to make ends meet upon hearing about
Judy getting her own show he wrote her a
congratulatory letter telling her if you
ever need a bailiff I still look good in
uniform amazingly shine Lim replied that
they were in fact looking for a bailiff
and the rest is history
the curious clipboard it's impressive
enough that bailiff bird basically
charmed his way into becoming an
indispensable character on one of the
most successful daytime TV shows of all
time but what he actually does during
filming elevates him to legend status
Bird revealed to Hollywood today live
what's really on that clipboard he's
always holding crossword puzzles yep
while Sheindlin is busy hurling vicious
one-liners of the poor schlubs standing
in a TV courtroom bird is getting paid
to play word games thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out his cool
stuff we know your love to
you